okay
everything works good
hi I'm going to talk about the quantum
complexity of the continuous head
intercept or problem but before I'm
going to do that I always start with a
few announcement first announcement is I
don't hear very well so if you have a
question I would like to ask you if you
would articulate it a little bit more
than you usually would and it's also
possible that I walk to you to be closer
to you to hear you better
please it's for that's just to make it
work a little bit better
oh yes this is joint work with layer do
car yeah so maybe many of you know
already the hidden subgroup problem
without the continuous one so that is
actually sort of a generalization of
plan factoring and discrete log in sort
of sense and this is again a
generalization of this hidden subgroup
problem instead of over finite groups
this is over continuous groups and we
mean with that like vector space are
vector spaces
let's start with the actual top give you
a small overview of this talk and I will
start with an introduction I will try to
motivate why this particular question is
interesting and I will also try to
explain where inspiration came from
that's always very important the next
one is the actual problem statement so
what is the hidden subgroup problem what
is the continuous hidden sub component
and it involves lattices so that is why
there is a lattice picture then I will
give you a global overview of a quantum
algorithm it will be a an intuitive
quantum algorithm as intuitive as
possible ok and the next one is I will
quickly go over open problems because
there's still much to do in this topic
and I would love to see other people
work on it as well because it is it's
really a beautiful topic and I will
finish with an error analysis because
this quantum algorithm it in using some
assumptions it definitely works but if
you drop those assumptions you need to
put a little bit more effort in it to
make it work start with the introduction
so the main inspiration of this work
came from this paper of eisentrager
Hellgren guitar and so gives a quantum
algorithm that computes the unit group
of number fields and here is where this
successful generalization of the hidden
subgroup is constructed is
so they made a successful generalization
of their in subgroup to the continuous
hidden subgroup and they also gave a
quantum algorithm that solves it use
this this as a black box to compute unit
groups in number fields and I would like
to stress that unit groups computation
in on classical computers are believed
to be very hard
I mean prime factoring you can compare
it with that prime factor factor into
primes is also believed to be hard on
classical computers but on quantum
computers it's easy and this is has a
similar flavor say unit groups are hard
on classical computers but on quantum
computers it is it easy for the crypto
people because this is actually I mean
this is a crypto oriented seminar so
this is used to prove a quantum hardness
gap between audio SVP and SVP so SV P
stands for shortest vector problem and I
do s VP is finding a shortest vector in
a structured that is and this is finding
a shortest factor in an arbitrary
lattice so apparently if your lattice is
well if if your that is based on an
ideal structure is it is easier than if
your lattice is not based or the ideal
structure and this was I mean a while
ago this was believed to be equally hard
that is where some crypto systems were
based on this
this actually showed that there that it
is actually not equally hard
I will go over an informal problem
statement so we will go to the formal
one as well but first I want to give you
some flavor even a nice periodic
function like this find its period it
seems so easy but it's remarkably hard
if you are only allowed to sample a
finite amount of points and you can also
generalize this to higher dimension so
here more psychedelic is an example in
two dimensions and now the period is a
lattice so that is an insight in higher
dimensions the period of a function is
encoded by a lattice so the the problem
statement becomes given this function
find this lattice yes okay let's go to
the formal stuff
now f is your function your periodic
function we are given black box access
to a function f from the real space real
vector space to a set of states quantum
states
so we already allow this function f to
be quantum already doesn't need to be
that we allow it to be and you could
think of the state of the set s as the
states of an N cubed register or states
of an N cubed register and this this
function should satisfy the following
conditions first condition is of course
periodicity I mean this is the bare
minimum I mean if you want to find the
lattice your function so just at least
be periodic second thing is that F
should satisfy some some smoothness I
should be a little bit of regular if it
hopes up and down it we cannot really
find periodicity in it the last
condition is the most technical one it's
called separable it means that the
function shouldn't be two constant so
I've made a picture here for you this is
a separable function and this is known
separable so if it is two constant
we cannot extract information out of it
in the most difficult example the
function is just flat and then it is it
is periodic with respect to any lattice
right so it should be a little bit non
constant non constant enough and it's
written here this is at the form of
statement I don't want to put too much
effort
given the periodic function lips it's
continuous and separable we want to have
a approximate basis of the lattice so
yeah the idea is that you have a fixed
lattice in mind so for example think
about the log unit lattice of a of a
number field so if you're you can
trivially just put yeah so if you don't
care about what that is you find of
course yeah but I want to stress one
more thing about this so this is only
needed when you want to sample multiple
lattice points milt we will see this
later but if you want to your dual
lattice to be fully renovated that is
what it means but you know we will go to
that later so we want the approximate
basis of the lattice that is the goal
any questions about the formal
okay oh that's a good point okay so if
you have a matrix a basis that's in a
matrix and you can consider a norm and
matrix norm like the Infinity the
infinite matrix norm and you just want a
matrix that is Tao close in the infinite
matrix norm to some bases of this
lattice contributions okay so what what
did we do we simplified the algorithm of
eisentrager at all and we also will find
the analysis so by simplification of
this algorithm you can do this analysis
way easier so what we did was instead of
starting with a sort of sinners
sinusoidal initial distribution we use a
Gaussian distribution to start with we
will see that later yeah and we came up
with the complexity that uses explicit
polynomials and has all dependencies of
parameters so maybe you remember the
Lipschitz constant that is in the
problem statement yes you remember the
Lipschitz constant so if your function
is very has a very high Lipschitz
constant what what is the influence of
the running on the running time that's
like that that is that is what we did
write to you it looks like this I'm
going to not going to talk about this I
have a very simpler more simpler version
so if your Lipset constant is not too
large the algorithm requires a cubic
amount of qubits
aquatic amount of quantum gates and a
linear amount of quantum queries to the
Oracle F and M here is the dimension of
your hidden lattice
I will go to the high-level approach of
the algorithm I also wrote it down here
the first sample approximate dual
lattice points and we do that using a
quantum algorithm that samples that the
clear is f in superposition we assemble
many of those do all that is and we put
them in a sort of approximate basis of
the dual lattice then we invert this
dual basis to get the primal basis and
primal basis means the basis of the
original period lattice this talk will
be mainly about the quantum algorithm
this is the only quantum step the other
steps are classical
before I want to do that I will explain
some important thoughts
important notion is the dual lattice the
dual lattice is sort of the inverse
lattice of your lattice if you make
primal lattice more sparse your dual
lattice becomes more dense so it's sort
of an inverse notion this is the
explicit definition and that's something
remarkable about those dual lattice
points because they you can define the
following sine functions those are
actually exponential with I here so it's
a like sine functions and those giant
functions form a basis of the lambda
periodic functions so I wrote it down
here as a sort of slogan like the sine
waves form a basis of periodic functions
like your Fourier analysis
so explicitly every nice lambda periodic
function can be written as a weighted
sum of those sine functions so those are
associated with dual lattice points this
is what we call the free a decomposition
of F M and those C L stars for L Stein
lambda star are called the Fourier
coefficients of F so they are always
associated with the dual lattice
have some I had some nice animation but
we will not wait for that and one more
important thought is a convolution
theorem so the way I am going to explain
the convolution theorem wouldn't be to
oh this is your function f then this is
actually the spectrum of f it goes on
here and there and those points here the
dual lattice points and the size of the
arrows are proportional to the size of
the Fourier coefficients this is how how
a Fourier decomposition of F looks like
but suppose now that we multiply F by a
Gaussian this is a notation for the
Gaussian then the Fourier transform of
this function looks like almost the same
with with some small Gaussian noise
around arrows
and I will go to the global idea by now
this global idea of the quantum
algorithm assumes that we have an
infinite amount of qubits we will drop
that assumption soon but for convenience
and for ease of thought you can just
imagine all the qubits so we create the
Gaussian superposition it looks like
this and we query F in superposition and
then the amplitudes will look like this
applying the Fourier transform we know
that that this is like the product of
the Gaussian x your function f so
applying the Fourier transform gives us
essentially the Fourier transform of F
with some small Gaussian noise and if
you now major quite understand how
varying the function also affected the
amplitudes you don't understand why what
affects the amplitude the function you
know at the points you will still remain
in the Gaussian superposition except
that you have the function value
entangled with the point so this is like
this is it's purely how do you say it to
graphic this so of course we should
think about this as this would be like
in the complex plane and should have a
face right so you have like the the
Gaussian function like this whap your
function goes like whoa stand a bit a
little bit what I mean
no I'm joking
look this is purely pictographic um so
what the function indeed this this
doesn't influences the amplitude in that
way but it still works in that sense
because if we if essentially we do a
measurement somewhere here
of the second register and then then it
works out like this yeah I didn't want
to include that I want to keep it a
little bit intuitive and that is why I
don't want it to to spoil too much but
with more words say okay koats F
interface amplitude and the Lipchitz
condition is on the function f or on the
sort of the function f in the exponent
so for that you need you want Lipschitz
for like e to the I times a so yes so
indeed so the func yeah yes so yeah so
that is what I wanted to show with the
weird gestures but yeah essentially yes
yeah so any more questions
right so we will drop the infinitude
assumption soon but first we will go to
the open questions because yeah it's
super interesting great so the first
thing that is five we would like to know
is the complexity of the Oracle
functions for the unit group and
principle ideal problem computation so
in this talk we assumed F to be assumed
F to be an Oracle function we can just
query it but in reality this function
needs to be computed right it is a
quantum function so we would like to
know what is actually the complexity of
that function and this is already that's
already ongoing work by EOS and so the
next questions is is are there
assumptions on the function f that make
the complexity better so we only assume
that F is lips yet but it could be very
smoother and we would like to know if if
it is a little bit more smoother would
it affect the complexity also in a good
sense
great the third open question is suppose
you know the suppliers of this hidden
sub lattice not a full rank sub lattice
but some sub lattice will that affect
the complexity would that help you
this is for the principal your problem
you can use it in the principal
and then the next open problem is
classically those this part here has a
terrible numerical stability so if we
make an error here this makes this error
very bigger you would like to know if
there's an analysis of this particular
part of the algorithm that that makes
the error not too big and that could
save you a factor m in the complexity
that would be very very good not sure
about that but it might be and this is
one also one of the most interesting
ones so you have symmetries often in
your lattice think about number fields
with a Galois group then your lattice
you are do lattice of your unit group
has a Galois symmetry can you exploit
Galois symmetry to improve the
complexity of this algorithm
that's about those open questions
oh the images after recovering what
vector will pry complexity to get many
or do you want something even better for
example yeah
but how would it for example impact the
numerical yeah so you want to improve
events of queries of quantum fence using
[Music]
let's go back to the global idea and the
main problem is that quantum computers
only have finitely many qubits so what
we need to do is we need to discretize
it and we need to window it and also one
one thing is that this Fourier transform
becomes a finite Fourier transform you
cannot do a a Fourier transform over the
wheels can only do fine it quantum so
let's do it
let's just do it without just discretize
it and the first thing looks still quite
nice and after clearing f still looks
sort of nice but I want to show you this
without the lines to give you an
intuition why it could be hard to see
periodicity so if you get this bunch of
points you don't see immediately
periodicity right so this this gives you
an intuition why you need many points
you need many queries
in the ideal case it is the creator's
form restricted to the grid so this is
something that we can analyze we know
what this function is but in the actual
case we do the finite Fourier transform
and that might deviate from this real
creators form because the finite
creators form cannot read between the
dots and the finite fourier transform
can only see what happens on the dots
and not in between so it loses
information and that with the lost of
information it has some noise
and the actual question is is this
closed in the l2 norm the l2 norm is a
general measure if this is close to that
in the l2 norm it means that the
probability of sampling doesn't differ
too much questions are how fine most
this grid be and how is it related with
the parameter I a
Oh - so how did we analyze this we went
from the grid to the real space and the
great looks like this I'll show you the
great lookk looks like this and the free
a transform on the grid of the function
with this this messy thing
and we showed that we have shown in our
work that this is actually equal to the
free a transform on the unit cube so we
move the gridlines here we have just a
continuous Fourier transform but only on
the unit cube and the next step is going
to a free a transform over the entire
real space and that is something that we
can analyze so this is something that we
can compute on a quantum computer and
this is something that you can do
mathematical stuff with and the
techniques we used to show that those
are close to using Jackson theorem using
Jackson theorem says something about
optimal to going to metric approximation
and this the way we showed that this is
close is a more famous technique namely
the processing of summation formula
yeah yeah so spoiler okay and we also
use a smoothness and bana stick bounce
but that that what was reserved for the
latest five latest more late slides but
anyway any questions about this
do you make sure you oh yeah so oh yeah
this is very valid question you can
always make your letters more sparse by
if you query f you can also clearly F
but we put we first compute we make F
faster so instead of querying F we query
F times F and V times your input so you
just first apply some scaling to your X
and then you apply F and it means that
that your hidden lattice becomes one
over V lambda so you can make your dual
lattice sparser just by doing this and
so it doesn't really so we can keep this
in a fixed way and just make and it does
influence the running time because if
you do this the Lipschitz constant goes
up
next
if this close to that yes we need we
need we need Q Q is the amount of points
here the number of points we need that
to be bigger than M to the power M times
your lips it's constant and the log of
this number that is the number of qubits
this can everybody see this tastic yeah
great oh and now I want to do some
bonacic things so if we are here we are
not really done because this looks like
that we are done if we sample something
here then the distribution
yeah the probability that we sample
something close to the dual lattice
point is expected to be quite big but we
still have to do some work
this function here the line the gray
line satisfies is exactly this function
do we all agree on this this is the
Gaussian centered at the dual lattice
point and we just sum over all dual
lattice points with some constant and
this constant are how high those hills
are and those are all centers of the
Gaussian and we know from the law of
quantum mechanics that if you take the
square of this function then is this the
probability of sampling X and we want to
show that so that the probability of
sampling an X close to a dual lattice
point lambda 0 star is equal to almost
equal to its Fourier coefficients square
that make sense so if and if you take
the sum of all three coefficients you
get 1
can actually compute the square by
taking two sums you arrive at this sum
and what we do is we split this sum in
two parts the first part is where K and
L star are equal and the second part is
where they are not equal and I want to
show you that this part is actually very
small because one Gaussian this is not a
Gaussian if you multiply those get
something very small because at this
point this is really small and at that
point this one is really small if you
multiply this it's small
okay so we can quit this one out that
only this one and if X is close to Elst
zero star the only Gaussian that matters
is the Gaussian with respect to this l0
star like a Gaussian like this there's a
sum of two gaussians if you have a point
close to this l0 star then the the only
Gaussian that really matters is this one
the influence of this Gaussian on the
value of this on this point is very
marginal that means that we only need to
do only keep one part of the Sun we only
keep the l0 star part
and now to put this value here
and they put the free a proficient
outside look and now we are going to use
bonacic and smoothness and so smoothness
is a technique by - chika and Missy on
saw or the gaff they show that this is
actually very close to 1 this is equal
to
this was the last part of the analysis I
will give you some summary so
multi-dimensional periodic functions
have a periodic period lattice functions
have Fourier coefficients of the dual
lattice points quantum computer can
sample approximate dual lattice points
and enough dual lattice points gives a
approximate basis of the period lattice
good thank you for the notion of
closeness when I explained the last part
so this is quite hand wavy but all those
notes are all l2 notions so this all in
the l2 distance we have you have a
amplitude over over your space
approximation the Tau approximating is
something different because that's the
approximation of your of your lattice
point the approximation here is actually
an error so I want to show here that two
two distributions are close distributes
is coming from a quantum state are close
you use that you then then you use the
l2 norm
do I make sense if I understand
correctly the idea is that you la
sampling do lattice points yeah and for
that you are summing up our
probabilities of observing points that
are close to that yeah so then the
question is so I mean so there are the
support of the distributions is not the
same you are actually taking some kind
of a projection so so it's not quite an
l2 distance between and there are two
things here I mean one is how do you
construct your dual lattice points from
approximate samples X so in your
summation you have X close to l0 star
okay yes so there's also another
parameter involved in in the the main
theorem say it's called Delta it stands
for a distance and this Delta can be
made arbitrarily small but you have to
pay for it of course
and so what is actually what is what
does it mean well actually remain X X
being in a ball Delta close to a dual
lattice point this Delta is like closely
related to spread deviation of this
Gaussian will make a little bit more
sense now so it is
so yeah you can make this all
mathematically sound where it will take
quite some effort in time you can wait
with the paper
what of the function the radius of what
yes the radius a Gaussian has as
Gaussian doesn't really have just
deviation so that's so this deviation
that that's like an input so this this
depends on the input right so we have
like a delta here and this Delta is
closely this is an input given like how
close do you want to be to your lattice
points and that is again related to this
tau at the very beginning so this Sigma
is it is not precisely given here but
it's sort of related with the input
input
[Applause]